years ago because you guys said the 127
150 000 like that oh I live my life
Collision that's how I got here that's
how I've been able to grow and get out
of poverty if I didn't think
delusionally and I listened to what
everyone said I would be I probably
would not be here right now okay
delusional I think be delusional be a
little crazy yeah and then how old would
you have to be before you'd be like you
know what
is there an age where you'd like lower
the standards no okay never no so so
okay
I think
I'm just thinking like okay geriatric
pregnancies at 35. yeah yeah 37 38 it's
not looking good you probably it's
probably over with rough yeah roughly
over with so like at what age are you
like you know what
she said never you know but at that
point I wouldn't lower my standard I
just simply would find something else to
occupy my time maybe I would be
childless maybe a dog maybe start doing
heroin there's so many options other
than lowering Wednesday she got a couple
ideas you know this is insane well I I
think it's so normal though because
again we have to remember her age right
every single 24 year old thinks like
this every single one I will never ever
ever I think I have been not my world
I'm like now 29 and I can tell you so
that's what I'm saying I was the problem
in relationship
I'm turning I'm 28 I'm turning 29. but a
little different girl but generally
speaking every woman when she's 20 22 to
23 she's in the prime of her career a
prime of her let's say sexual market
value in her and she's like why would I
lower anything look at all that I've got
because she's not me she's not able to
see she's not there now he's going to be
at 33 and 35. she also doesn't have
these biological clocks ticket at 22 and
24 like she's gonna have at 35 and 37
right yeah and so to ask her to see and
and to to guess how she's going to feel
15 years into the future like there's
just there's no way she can seek it I
also know I've lowered my standards in
the past when I was younger and people
might say I was more in my Prime
though for the reasons that you might
lower your sins in the future you have
no idea what that looked like it looks
you're right I don't I think when I was
22 and 24 I definitely had like a not
like delusional but like hopefully I'll
look or
misinformed Outlook because I didn't
have the experience and going through
like a couple of relationships and I was
dating I thought that those each time I
was in that relationship that I was
working towards something I blamed
especially the breakups like I was
cheated on in multiple relationships and
I blamed them like you're an [__]
you're the worst like all of this stuff
I never looked inward of like how I was
like affecting that and just thought I
deserve the best and deserved all of
that
now as I'm getting like older I I had to
take an inward look at myself and be
like okay maybe your shit's not ice
cream maybe you need to work on yourself
to be that person you know what I mean
and then you take a step back and then
you can kind of like readjust I don't
think I think a lot of women do spend
majority of their lives in that like
mindset from when they're 22 and it
never leaves and they don't do any of
the work internally to or like to be
that person that deserves all of that
stuff but you committed you know you
committed to the delusion I also don't
think I'm at the level where I would
date the person that I want to date like
I don't think I'm there yet and a lot of
women think they're there and they're
they don't have to do anything to be
there I think you do have to put in work
and like Jamie said heal yourself and do
the inner work and maybe you have to go
to wife school or learn etiquette
there's things you can do to improve
yourself so you can get to that level
where it's not delusion and it's like oh
I'm on this level this is what I'm
bringing into the table and now I can
meet somebody at the same level I don't
think I'm at that level where I can get
that guy in that one are you saying like
emotionally like where where you're at
emotional definitely emotionally I think
I'm still very immature this is what I
mean when I just I feel like it's women
like we just say things
but do you not like think that if we
want somebody on that level we would
have to work to get there at 24 years
old you will never be more valuable than
you are right now
she
that's right yeah I guess to the average
man
be delusional baby I don't look it I'm
glad you laugh Lee
I mean I don't know I it can't be that a
hundred percent of a woman's value is
wrapped up in her looks at 24. it's not
early we're ability to have a child it's
the idea that
it's the idea that
the older she gets
the more body she gonna rack up
the more men that she's gonna go through
the more trauma she's going to
experience
and then at some point
based off of what they're saying they
they're gonna still live in the delusion
so no I I agree with you
any stock in what she says the 24 year
old talking about she's never gonna
settle
that's like talk to me in five years
yeah we'll see in five years is
oh you know do you like girls do you
want to kiss girls like no oh that's
disgusting this is what this is what it
is ask me a 24 year old she's gonna
settle right because she's she's not
she's not gonna see it right so you
can't you can't count the problem with
that is that she's old enough to start
her only fans
and then she's old enough to [__]
and she's old enough to go out here and
make some decisions that's that she'll
never be able to undo you'll never be
able to not have that content out there
floating in in space somewhere you'll
never be able to take some of this stuff
back
so the value that you have is in your
decisions to not make bad decisions
that's why age is a factor not just in
what it is that you look like but it's
in the decisions that you make that's
gonna that she's gonna have to carry for
the rest of her life I agree with you I
actually I agree with you on it but the
perspective that we're looking at from
and like that lens is there are women
who at 35 they spent their life having
these like thoughts and these standards
and they get there and they don't do the
work so when you say they have more the
reason they're more valuable when
they're younger at 24 is because they
don't have as much baggage from being
with multiple women and everything those
are people who are not healing their
baggage like absolutely if you're a 35
and you can't get married because you
never did any of the work to heal that
and you're not taking like a fresh start
with like you should really hear what
men think when you say healing overall
oh my God I can't believe you just said
that because I was thinking yeah
out I'm telling you you got to stop
saying so what do men think oh my god a
woman is trying to heal oh they think
they then you can say otherwise so after
you're gonna be like that's not what I
meant I'm telling you no matter what you
say next this is what they hear oh
absolutely I've been ran through
I'm not I mean you guys already have the
only fans so that doesn't help
um but like
I'm just being honest like telling you
know guys see it you know look it I've
been ran through I've been at the club
I've been healing under as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible